we must have something is coming you can
feel that cake you can feel that we are
creeping towards the edge I know you're
out there I know that you are in pain
munch alarm here to tell you that
suffering is choice and you can choose a
better path if you want you accept you
and we will take you willingly or not
and some of you may fight but in the end
you will think I am your father
and you are my children
[Music]
and we
[Music]
[Music]
the end is upon us I shall leave you for
the data for you are my children and I
am your father
[Music]
you
I grew up here you know and my first
kiss out back with some dumb cowboy back
up on my dad he loved this place
it wasn't all easy but he always made
sure that here you could speak your mind
and then they showed up here to help
they said you believe them and then they
took my mom my brother dad was never the
same
[Music]
now what take this place to
no this place is ours
[Music]
woe to the man who leads my flock astray
cellphone
we were given so much this land this
life our freedom
[Music]
what's left on it now how people
felt abandoned grew weary they needed
our help
and we didn't listen but he did told
them exactly what they wanted to hear
but those falsehoods lies is poison it's
driven them from pasture and the
righteous path' woe to the man lead my
flock astray if I am NOT THERE shame
then I must be the war
[Music]
she's a beaut ain't she
all this time they never let me down I
just hope she's around when he's old
enough to fly oh my boy I mean hope it's
a boy
I just wanted to farm like I do not like
my dad I'm my grandpa
they flew in the war so I didn't have to
but now I don't know if you'll ever have
the chance nobody is around here people
are scared man I may never have gone to
war Peggy's come after [ __ ] them sure as
hell we'll give them one
[Music]
you
you